hola muy buenos días y claro que el
instituto creo que monitorea el acuerdo
de paz en el marco del mandato que le
fue otorgado como parte del componente
internacional de verificación durante
estos cuatro años nosotros hemos visto
que ha habido avances importantes sobre
todo en el diseño de los planes y
programas que van a fundar las bases
para lo que tiene que ver con la reforma
rural que es uno de los puntos más
importantes del acuerdo también es de
destacar todo el proceso en los primeros
años de especial fuego y dejación de
armas que se cumplió de manera bastante
oportuna gracias al compromiso de las
partes en la transición de las farc como
un grupo armado guerrillero a una fuerza
política en el marco de la democracia
también ha sido uno de los eventos tal
vez más significativos el mantenimiento
del acompañamiento internacional el
componente internacional de verificación
que ha permitido hacer seguimiento a
toda la implementación del acuerdo de
paz y sobre todo brindar apoyo
financiero para el mismo y la creación
de toda la arquitectura institucional
para que la implementación avance es
decir estamos durante los primeros años
se sentaron como las
para lo que tiene que ser ahora y hemos
destacado nuestro cuarto informe esta
transformación territorial si ahora en
su opinión que puntos de la
implementación se han visto más
afectados por estado de la violencia hay
que esperar del gobierno de presidente
duque
bueno fundamentalmente la implementación
se ve afectada en general
en todos los puntos por la violencia no
solamente por el asesinato de líderes
sociales y ex combatientes que es uno de
los puntos fundamentales que el acuerdo
busca ofrecer una serie de mecanismos
para su protección sino para la
confianza y la legitimidad del proceso
en términos generales para la población
hay muchas instituciones que hacen parte
del acuerdo como la comisión para el
esclarecimiento de la verdad la búsqueda
de personas edad por desaparecidas que
tienen que desarrollar sus acciones en
territorio y las acciones violentas y la
presencia de grupos armados ilegales
impiden que se avance con estos temas
que son cruciales para el cumplimiento
de los derechos para las víctimas en ese
sentido es muy importante que haya un
mayor compromiso en la protección de los
líderes y en la implementación integral
de las garantías de seguridad que ofrece
el acuerdo así que si bien no son
suficientes y si son necesarias para
complementar lo que ya viene haciendo el
esfuerzo en materia de mecanismos de
protección
cit danielle muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros aquí en
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz
sábado